Robert first question
on Robert Lata BSO when draymond was in
here Steph he said that he felt like a
lot of people look at this like a ending
to you guys's run but that would be a
mistake on their part can you talk about
the resiliency of your team and if
indeed you've you had that feeling as
well and should people not put you guys
in the grave right now
tough tough way to go out you gotta see
credit to run on on a great series they
they went out one it they played amazing
tonight all across the board they had
contributions and yeah it's a tough
feeling you know being on this side of
losing in the finals but I think a lot
has been you know proven about who we
are as a team and the fight that we have
and all the adversity that we dealt with
you know this entire playoff run and you
know it's a one-possession game to keep
our season alive tonight so it would be
thinking about this one it's tough but
our DNA and who we are and you know the
character that we that we have on this
team I wouldn't bet against us you know
being back on the stage you know next
year and in going forward so really
proud of the way that we fought to the
end and this five year runs been been
awesome but definitely don't think it's
over next question right here I'm Julian
Herrera ABC 7 News despite the loss can
you just talk about all the emotions
you're feeling that this is the last
game at Oracle I mean for these fans
this is this is their Oracle they love
this place and what are you feeling now
that this is really over a lot of
different emotions a lot of thoughts no
regrets at all but again what we've been
able to accomplish and even how this
series ended so we've had a lot of great
memories in this building I think it's a
its iconic in the sense of our entire
history of this organization and
and how we got to this point and you
know whenever I Drive by it I'll have
great memories again what we've been
able to accomplish in this building and
as we move move across the bridge want
to be able to continue that and create
new memories so hopefully you know every
fan that was in this building
appreciates the journey in the ride
every fan that was watching how Oakland
held us down for 47 years and turned the
page to to you know bigger and better
things you know coming for this
franchise fourth row on your right stuff
stuff might get a Toronto Sun um you saw
a lot of Fred vanvleet in this series
what do you know about him now that you
didn't know before me as a gamer he had
some big shots not just the affairs of
pressure he did a lot of daggers that I
never seen to you know paint it when the
ball was and it was it was in his hands
and even tonight
he had like three of them that kept a
momentum on their side
so obviously saw a lot of bodies on
defense but uh you know he was one that
took the challenge and and obviously
he's a champion now so well deserved
stuff comparing the the way you lose
three years ago in the finals this is
like almost got shut down at a very
second very very last second in the game
seven to this finals you know there's so
many injuries so many people got there
so which one is more painful for you
guys I mean losing hurts no matter what
the situation is you nobody likes that
feeling whether it's a game seven or
game six or what-have-you but you know
I'll echo what dream unsaid it's kind of
how do you respond and what do you you
know how hard do you work to try to get
back to the stage
you know soak up this feeling because
obviously we celebrated with a champagne
we've had no rings but this is the more
motivating feeling
how do you respond how do you turn the
page to new challenges ahead so will be
I mark Janey and then Howard last three
stiff mark Schwartz ESPN first can you
explain how you felt watching clay go
down and secondly how much did you have
left at the end when you had that look
to possibly put your team ahead and go
on to Game seven
it's just tough in terms of a guy like
clay that left it all out there he put
his playing amazing tonight there to see
a freak play like that where you know he
lands awkwardly I don't know the
diagnosis yet but you think about the
person and the guy and how much he loves
to play the game and that's the only
thoughts you have it's really not about
you know what it means in terms of
playing basketball it's just I'm more
concerned about him as an individual and
and hoping that he's alright so I can
you know leave it at that but the shot
was when I take ten out of ten times and
you know we ran a play that was kind of
we got a decent look off of you know
kind of a bobble catch and I you know I
was conceited rim so I shot it I'll live
with it we always talked about that you
know myself and clay in terms of shots
that we take you live with it and you
know I'd shoot that shot every every day
of the week
Jani back Center Steph Janie McCauley
from Associated Press you've said so
many times this season you know how
difficult it is to win it all and how
you guys need to cherish every moment
together while this team is together to
do the events of the last couple days
where it where Kevin has surgery and
clay goes down just just show you how
many things have to go right for a
special a championship I mean and how
things sometimes don't don't work out
for sure I mean the history of this NBA
you could I
like every team that was supposed to win
or had the best team and all the
different storylines and you know 82
games and a full playoff run a lot can
happen and just no matter how much you
fight and just leave it all out there on
the floor I think the way that we have
talked and described this this journey
and whatnot I don't a there's ever been
a situation where we've taken anything
for granted and that's something I can
look back and just help hold up we all
can hold our head high that uh you know
we gave it everything we got to your
point about you know two guys who go
down and the game's kind of taken away
from them in those moments it's it's not
a good feeling at all and it's kind of a
helpless feeling in terms of you know
two free plays that you know send these
guys back to the to the locker room so
it's tough but it's part of the
basketball is part of the game again I
just you know hope their recoveries are
strong and they come back you know
better than they were before
Howard last question here in the left
side Howard back from Bleacher Report's
Steph when you think about the toll of
five-year run can take all the extra
games you think about some key free
agencies the injuries sean has talked
about possibly retiring does this feel
like if not necessarily the end then
kind of a major transition point for who
you guys have been you expect serious
change potentially coming forward I mean
I'm not sure there's a lot of obviously
decisions that will go into the summer
and we'll deal with those accordingly
but you know I think true champions like
we are we should be able to adapt and
keep the same kind of DNA no matter what
our roster looks like next year and I
have high hopes about you know being
back on the stage whether it looks the
same or not or obviously we're changing
buildings and all that type of stuff you
know there's gonna be some change but
we'll enjoy this summer like you said
it's been a long journey we've played a
lot of basketball get away from the game
a little bit refresh the minds
guys go through some rehabs and get get
back stronger your next season will be
next season and will come back with the
right mentality so it's kind of hard to
talk about because it's a tough way to
go out and stuff to lose in the finals
but story's not over yet thank you stuff